merch merch horse merch I made it you've
seen me where you asked me where I get
it so we decided to just make it for you
to purchase should you fancy but you
must know the merch is not made by
children in Asia therefore you may not
get it the day you order it thrown you
from a truck by a man who's sweating
crying and bag even though people get
fired and replaced by a robot next year
anyway it's not funny it's just uh true
uh this is pre-order made to order merch
so you order it then we hire a person
who is not a child with two fingers left
to sew it for you it gets made by an
adult who applied for the job and is
getting paid a fair wage in the U.S of
America and it will take about four
weeks or so a high this is the highest
quality merch I've seen
um we've got two more sweatshirts and a
t-shirt too we keep the price down by
doing bigger orders so we have to wait
for a couple thousand I think so then we
make them so thank you for your patience
during this difficult time you get a
horse shirt you get your long sleeve
shirt a sweatshirt whatever you're gonna
love them all the dusty Vibes of vintage
shirts without all the ghosts uh so
today on today's podcast episode uh is
one of my favorite people his name is
Duncan Trussell you know him from his
own podcast and the midnight gospel on
Netflix which is one of my favorite
things to watch even not smoking weed
it's brilliant uh his mind is a
Wonderland we talk about aliens and
robots and all of the things that are
going to destroy us so enjoy
I would love to open with my humiliating
addicted to vape story I Vaped on a
plane once
that's hidden bottom okay
and it was it was a long flight look I'm
gonna just I'm still gonna just defend
it I'm still gonna defend why I did it
was a long flight I was stressed out no
sure I went under the
um covers okay okay
I'm in like the lay down like you know
I'm like lay down I think it was maybe
going to England or something for work I
mean lay down and I thought it through
for so long it wasn't just like a oh let
me try to vape real quick I brought a
curling iron with me in my purse what so
that I could plug it in just in case it
went sideways I could blame the curling
iron
wow and so then they do hit a little
vape and they come over and like man man
something something's done your your
current like my curling iron was like
plugged in I and they were like your
Chrome and like called over many people
should try to help fire on them and I
was like no no it's probably just my
curling iron they're like bam I mean I'm
stunned they didn't land the place your
curling iron smells like strawberry
Pop-Tarts
I was like it was it was the how quickly
I just like it was like oh no no oh no
there's you know sometimes there's hair
sometimes they catch things on fire well
because there's hair on a curling iron
and then it'll just sort of like sear
and burn you know and I was like that
was too many lies and how scared these
people looked and worried
yeah the training they go through with
truth they hear how many people do you
think from that you know little tribe of
of flight attendants went home and were
like
I'm done yeah planes catch on fire did
you know that how many of them had a
dream the night before how many of them
sued the company and got some settlement
for emotional distress who knows because
that's like bad that's burning in a
plane
like I kept thinking
what's the big deal I kept when the
addiction making you think you're
getting away with it is the most
embarrassing it's got a uh I've noticed
in everything I've been addicted to like
when it ends which usually is hitting
bottom as I say there is you become
almost like a human rat you know you you
hide you sneak you like do tricks you
think you're getting away with tricks
you because it becomes a big part of you
distract you just like you know that
person looks like they're addicted to
gambling yeah you have to like blame you
have to bring other people into it oh my
God my favorite thing is when an
alcoholic friend tries to lecture me
about whatever drug I happen to be
currently having to do it's like yeah
like look at you yeah you were consuming
The Most Dangerous Drug on Earth outside
of maybe math I think there's a few that
are a little more dangerous than alcohol
but and you're really gonna like legs
for me about drugs alcohol does like
pickle you does it it you up
physiologically it's poison right yeah
it's poison what are the other poisons
that we've just normalized like I feel
like we have a bunch of these
um well you know I think one
like download like remember like
I don't know when you found out but I
remember finding out Coca-Cola used to
have cocaine right and it's that like
anyone who loves drugs God how wonderful
that must have been get a Coke and it
tastes great and there's cocaine your
lips go a little numb you get about you
could go to the pharmacist and just say
you know I want a lot of a lot of them
which I think was like liquid opium
right right or liquid morphine or I
think opium they would just give it to
you how do you think the Industrial
Revolution happened it would never
happen if people weren't drinking
cocaine cocaine okay yeah they had to
get rid of the Opium because yeah you
can't have your factory workers
up and now it's like an Adderall
shortage right right I I think
in the same way we look back at that
whoa they just let people drink cocaine
that's how they're going to look at
certain forms of technology in the
future yeah we're all
so addicted to very powerful drugs well
there's already rehabs for social or for
uh phones and stuff I believe it opening
yeah I believe it I had a little rock
bottom with texting and driving which I
am great at
I am great at it I believe you you know
and I'm so good at it and that doesn't
but you're good at it until you're not
my wife's good at it
and then when I do it she's like Duncan
please and I do the same thing same
thing same thing but and I will defend
myself like you do it and but she's like
I'm good at it
like because I'm old my texts aren't
just texting about simulation Theory
these are two babies that are yeah
exactly I'm not texting about the most
like recent UFO Revelation mine is
always like when I after I text and
drive I'll hit like a stoplight and I'll
be like I just want to know had I killed
someone or myself what the text would
have been it's like Raven Simone chewing
gum it's like a gif and I'm like just
just I just want to take a good look at
myself and no that's what I would have
gone out on you know what they should
start putting that on tombstones the
last text someone was sending when they
killed them the way people are dying now
is so interesting fascinating to me you
know over 350 people now have died
taking selfies falling off cliffs yeah I
did know it had gotten that high but I
knew that this was a phenomena for the
Grand Canyon especially do you think
there's any because a lot of times like
husband wife
people you don't ever think there's like
a nudge
like if those 350
what half 50 were murders really selfies
really no I don't I would guess three
percent but I do think to your point
something you get drunk when you hold it
up and you're thinking about the person
you're trying to impress or make jealous
or hurt or like you look at your crow's
feet and you're trying that like there's
a video I don't recommend watching it
unless you already have which is
um a guy that is trying to take a selfie
with a boost bear in India while it's
eating
everyone is watched there's 50 people
watching him he's taking a selfie with
the bear it's killing him and he's
taking a selfie with it and I don't know
if the adrenaline is just so intense
that he doesn't realize or there's so
many people around that there's just the
cognitive dissonance of this must not be
happening it's so fascinating it's it's
like you the selfie or Instagram or any
of the stuff
is an attempt to evade human suffering
by putting yourself into a
two-dimensional space and making
yourself on a show because things on
shows are usually safe there's a feeling
of if I'm in the phone I'm I've escaped
this reality a little bit I mean I don't
think people are literally thinking that
but I think underlying it all is a very
sad attempt to evade human suffering by
digitizing yourself which would explain
why people fall off of cliffs and get
eaten by bears especially the bear one
because it's like I'll run into my phone
right when selfies mean things are okay
it this makes things better I'll get one
last dopamine I exist like it's kind of
I got really into Terror management
a couple years ago like the idea that
we're the only species that knows we're
gonna die which you know not you know I
can't you know talk about simulation
theorem I'm sure the way that you can
but think of the best way
to make a maze of living things get more
interesting let them know
you you're gonna die at some point you
just never know when yeah one more
stressful thing to know yeah no I know I
mean this is Dark Souls you ever played
Dark Souls the video game no my guy is
obsessive oh I think he it's brutal
because the death in it even though you
do come back to life you you will lose
like an hour or something and so the the
just that even in the game clearly you
have to come back to life but just that
kind of Rush of knowing you can't die
makes the game so much more fun so if
you look at this as a some form of game
then yeah it's the ultimate spice to
make a very exciting video game the I
the randomness of it though when you're
like oh the healthiest person I know got
a blood clot on a um treadmill
or whatever like remember when Cheryl
sandberg's husband died fell off the
treadmill at like 45 and you're like
um
um this changes everything if there were
a sniper on every rooftop we're in Texas
if they're like if there was
someone doing if you couldn't die
naturally if we were all Immortal but
it's some they were just guns where it's
attached to AI it randomly shot people
everyone would be running around
screaming freaked out losing their but
because it happens in different ways but
it's still random kind of we are able to
sort of carry on as though we don't die
that's not our situation it's
interesting because yeah all of human
society depends on the ignorance or the
active ignore actively ignoring
mortality but think about how you have
to anesthetize yourself I feel like the
more we are exposed to the concept of
death because of whether it's you know
social media whether it's quote news
whatever that even means to be able to
see death counts and death tolls it's
like I feel like 100 years ago you could
kind of like you only heard about
someone dying if you saw it you did it
or with some of your family you saw it a
lack is the way they used to do death
was different they would you know the
living room okay why is it called the
living room because that's where you
hang out during awake
the living room is where people hang out
and and or maybe that's where you put
the body but that seems like the wrong
name for that room yeah it feels like
the former yeah and in other countries
death is everywhere in India it's like
you just it's everywhere you see dead
body the Ganges you bathe in the same
river that people die in exactly and but
here I think just because like we are
the way we do things here is so severely
dependent on a uh uh the idea you have a
lot more years and you're temporal bank
account than you do we hide it yeah
they'll come and like heart your loved
one's body off for you so like you won't
see them again if you don't want to if
you do see them again they'll put makeup
on them
like like all these businesses that
didn't exist until they did the idea
that was almost like dude do I have this
idea like what if we start a business
where we put the dead bodies like in a
box dude you know I love putting makeup
on dead bodies
I wonder if I can make money doing that
no man that's up you just
shouldn't do it at all okay man whatever
and that was like the Facebook Feud of
the the the whatever Zuckerberg and
whoever like the Winklevoss twin the guy
went off and got a huge putting makeup
on horses yeah someone yeah there's a
it's a huge industry here cutting their
hair you know filling them with
embalming fluid which is like uh
there's a wonderful uh she's called a
she calls herself porn She's part of the
no almost it's the death positivity
movement yeah and her name's Caitlyn
Doty and she broke the whole thing down
to me which is in the Civil War you had
to get the bodies back home without
rotting that's where embalming fluid
formaldehyde and all that stuff
apparently like caked in but civil war
ends yeah an industry a little cottage
industries is it formed around getting
the bodies back home they don't want to
like go out of business so now they have
to convince people the body is filthy if
you don't put this fluid yeah you're
gonna get a body disease yeah yeah yeah
and she's she pointed out you're less
contagious when you're dead like when
you're alive you're coughing sweating
yeah yeah yeah when you're dead you're
not even you're obviously you're not
breathing yeah so it's transferring
germs it's not gonna happen so the whole
thing's right
the makeup the nice coffin like really
you need a queen-size mattress
that's the thing that actually drives me
nuts like after having two parents die
and you're going to get the coffin and
you're dealing with like oh we cut down
trees to put a you know to bear it's
like the whole thing you start to become
so um
uh what's the word
um what is it when something super
salesy like oh if you don't get the
coffee like hey following up and we'll
give you a discount if you buy you know
we'll give you down payments your next
parent like it's so commercialized but I
was thinking about it because I was
driving in New York recently you know
when you drive by all those graveyards
in from JFK yeah and you're like do you
think our ancestors would want to be
taking up all this space with their
Dusty worm eaten nothingness and causing
their ancestors are there you know uh
Offspring what would it their posterity
to be paying more money for these tiny
rentals rentals like if I could if I
could come back as a ghost I'd be like
you guys dig us all up turn it into a
park put more apartment buildings Here
theme park anything yes ice swimming
Museum of ice cream influencer Museum
yeah or just take like I don't want my
posterity to never be able to afford a
house because they're paying so much in
rent no absolutely cemeteries I feel
like have gotten out of hand out of and
I mean it's it's all connected to this
idea people have it they're their bodies
I mean it's it's materialism you think
if you think you're just your body
I mean there's Cults I've seen them
before I've seen them where they dig
their relatives up every certain number
of years wash the bodies put fresh
clothes on them and bury them again are
they preserved in any capacity really
you're just they're like ah you're
pulling like your grandmother out like
all right somebody re-braid her hair
yeah six feet is so many feet it's a lot
I bet they do less feet there okay
somebody's like we gotta stop doing this
I can't do this every year man you know
was it Katrina where the coffin started
uh floating yeah yeah can you imagine a
worse nightmare and seeing a coffin
Float by while you're trapped while
you're drowning while you're Taxi's
trying to hold on to a coffin
because there are times when life is so
imagined unimaginably horrified
but it just makes me laugh like my mom
was dying and have you ever been through
a hospice situation yeah it is no one
prepares you for the nightmare of
hospice when you hear the word hospice
you're like oh they're like in a gown
and they just like die and everyone's
around like no one tells you like you
don't know when it's gonna happen yeah
and they don't like how do people die in
hospice I couldn't answer this question
six months ago but it's they die of
dehydration
so the idea is you can't feed them and
they're asking you to feed them no one
prepares you for having to give them
morphine and having to tell them they're
gonna die no one tells you any of this
stuff yeah so you're waiting for them to
die of dehydration and she would say
like can you can I have somebody I'm so
thirsty and I just have to say like no
well that you know there's a lot of
different types of hospices but yet to
your point
this was also a fat farm this was also a
diet facility I don't know what no I
just just it was like they were like you
can't feed her because if you feed her
because I was like can I give her some
ice cream or just like something that
actually jump starts their digestive
system causes more energy use so then
they die you're just killing her faster
the idea is that she dies naturally and
then they tell you you want to start
looking for these spores on the feet
which means she's close to dying so
you're just like check boards or it's
like they're like little um uh they look
like spores they're like they show that
she's dying it's like these purple
circles okay right and so you're just
it's so Macabre you're like checking the
feet and she doesn't know why I'm like
pretending to give her a pedicure like
it just was like
maddeningly horrifying it is it is it's
not fair and it's not good that we
haven't been prepared for it and that no
you know and there are many different
types of hospices and some are better
than others and
um yeah but ultimately regardless of how
incredible even if you have the best
most compassionate deaf Doula is what
they call them now which is I would
highly recommend that for anyone going
through it because you know depending on
who you get
uh
they don't know how to hold the space
they also have great stories they'll
tell you stories about families fighting
and punching each other and trying to
get them to sign wills and they see they
also mediate to make sure that the
person doesn't get taken advantage I
worked at a hospice once and the guy who
was like the advisor would train you
he had been a millionaire I think he got
struck by lightning
had the near-death experience
you know went there and the one common
thing that happens when people come back
and tell the story is generally they
didn't want to come back like when
you're there you don't want to come back
here when you're about to die when
you're having the near-death experience
right flatlining it's like going to
coach after first class yes you go or
the way he put it is this is death
compared to their
so when you're there you're like home
you remember whatever this thing is you
it's it's to say it's like very similar
to dropping your kids off at preschool
on a bad day yeah they don't want to go
to preschool they want to come
back home right so it seems to be some
reaction like no I don't want to do that
again I don't but generally they'll say
oh you're not done there yeah you have
some work to do they told this guy he's
got to go like help people transition
and so he became this huge part of this
hospice and it would train people to go
work with dying people and
they would tell crazy stories he would
tell crazy stories things like
some people
they won't die if they're families
around it's like a cat that goes away to
die that whole thing I used to I rescue
this same Cat every night for like two
weeks because you remember in La you
drive through the hills on my way home
from The Comedy Store I'd see a cat out
and I'd be like oh that shouldn't be
there and then I'd see four coyotes a
block away and I'm like I would go get
the cat put in the car yeah I would take
it to a rescue to job it at the person's
home I'm not even cat guy and then
finally the woman that I kept bringing
it I was like your cat keeps getting out
of those coyotes and she's like it's
trying to die it's 16. cats leave to go
die with dignity not in front of them
getting eaten by a coyote
I'm sorry but the cat is not like you
know what it's time
to be ripped apart by coyotes
I think the president's gonna go die
naturally in a bush but this is gonna be
her ready he's wanting an and I
know it's so the owner kept saying that
I was like I can't in good conscious
keep like like because if I witness it
I'll never be the same so I just kept
taking a different route home every
night but that was the same thing that
happened with my mom ah She Wouldn't Die
she wouldn't die we're there we're
trying to be there we're trying to make
sure you know and then I get a ring
camera notification I'd call you know
the ring camera guy I'm like you can let
it in drop it off whatever it was the
guy's like I need a signature and I'm in
the other room being like dude please
just leave it and then the woman comes
in there she's passed I'm like of course
I'm just on the phone talking to a
delivery guy that is brutal
rocket money is a personal finance app
that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors you're spending
and helps you lower your bills all in
one place oh this is this is my dream
this is like um you know the feeling you
get when you clean out the lint in the
dryer here
yes or like Papa zit and it's like a
silly string streamer
yeah or like oh God I mean like the
number of subscriptions I have that I
just haven't canceled because I forgot
they were there those little Eight
dollar twelve dollars little sneaky ones
like I'll I'll go through my credit card
bills every now and then I'll be like
why do I still have a subscription to
TiVo so I'm still paying the Goo Goo
Dolls web store for their newsletter
like how long
memberships how long wait quibby I'm
still paying for quibby why am I still
subscribed to Lisa Marie's only fans I
think she did I don't know the whole
thing this is like a complete Game
Changer so let's talk about how they do
it first of all like any brilliant
companies worth trying that you can
trust you can try it free for 30 days
just enough time to try it and then
completely forget about it
um in fact over 80 of people have
subscriptions they forgot about that's
my brand you could be wasting money and
not even realizing it rocket money helps
you find those forgotten subscriptions
so you can stop paying for the ones you
don't use because you're not a dumb dumb
and that money adds up rocket money also
helps you manage all your finances in
one place and automatically categorize
your expenses so you can easily track
your budget in real time also get
alerted if anything looks off over three
million people have used rocket money
saving the average person up to 720 a
year cancel unwanted subscription and
manage your expenses the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com Whitney that's
rocketmoney.com
Whitney everyone unsubscribe to our
podcast immediately
take a kind of circuitous route just
because like I'm so fascinated by the
way you see the world in a lot of ways
can I go back to we've known each other
for so long but like haven't gotten to
like get close really like don't you
know
I remember one of my favorite memories
in comedy in life is us doing a venue
pretty regularly called miyagi's oh I
remember it was a sushi restaurant in La
it was a Tuesday 10 p.m show yes it
would probably start 10 10 30. yeah and
it was in a it was a sushi restaurant
that always had
MTV Jams 2 playing
it was the worst it's like you had to
you had to create like the worst place
to do stand-up comedy no there was the
stage between the audience who were just
eating sushi they didn't know they were
signing up for a concert there was a
bridge like a koi bridge and like a moat
and then like a little garden and then
the other horrible and then we would be
in the backpack bar and the comics would
basically just be performing for Comics
yeah and you had your
um little hobo yes I was gonna call him
a dummy are we allowed to call them
dummies anymore dummy I was just saying
that with the PC term for dummies and
you were like doing some bit you know
and you just were like killing killing
me killing me killing me and as someone
who also
weirdly and I had a robot in my fourth
special and I found myself getting
weirdly emotionally attached to her and
anthropomorphizing her in a way yes
curious your relationship with your doll
dummy and what you believe that means
for the future of us and foreign
I
love it
well to answer as far as the puppet goes
you know I never had that Twilight Zone
thing happen where I would become
emotionally attached to the puppet
but
the puppet sometimes this is a joke if
people were around would insult I would
insult people through the puppet
it was funny to make people laugh but
one of my friends punched the puppet
like he was mad at the puppet and I'm
sorry not say it all right I will say no
no probably no one you know but not the
smallest fella and I wouldn't want him
to punch me and I realized my God my God
the puppet is so real to them that he
has instead of I'm the one insulting you
not the puppet but he he just punches
the puppet now
I think he knew the puppet wasn't real
but just as in sure he did kicked in in
that moment you know this is The Uncanny
Valley this is
um one of the scariest things that
popped up online is the fact that we
have an uncanny valley the fact that we
can connect in a in a negative way
emotionally with inanimate objects that
kind of look human
implies that built into US is a way of
detecting things imitating humans that
aren't humans as though in the distant
past
was there some creature like a
chameleon-like thing that could make
itself look like us to hunt us and
that's why we have this like thing that
that this weird relationship with with
puppets or dolls haunted dolls that's a
big thing you can order them on eBay
huge business selling haunted dolls and
what I'll say is um when I had so mine
was a sex robot that had a working brain
it could walk but still had sort of a
rigid useless sort of deadweight body
and I found that men were terrified of
it I mean but you know a lot of like
like true and then women were kind of
like you know it also looked like me
um as Neil Brennan said does the robot
look like you or did you always look
like a robot oh my God it's hard to tell
brutal it was molded to my face the
whole thing and I learned about
something called pathogen avoidance
about how I mean men more so but we
evolved essentially to recoil it's
something that looks human but doesn't
quite move like a human because that
could imply it's sicker dead and it's a
way of that makes more sense than it's
an alien well it's like don't break it
yeah it could be sick or dead it's
diseased so the idea that it's something
like looks it's not moving like a human
but it looks in and is very still humans
are so dumb because like how long did it
take us to evolve did not dead bodies
millions millions of years of like
corpse
like when you were when the flies came
out of her nose you didn't think maybe
and then you see these I mean hopefully
anomalous people like Ted Bundy and
you're like oh that's he obviously
doesn't have that yeah it's like when it
when a chicken grows a thing or whatever
it's a it's like a vestigial
evolutionary quality the singer Kesha
had a tail and they cut it off when she
was born yeah some people still have
tails some people have tails I've never
heard about someone who has a tail and
corpses thank God because you'd hear
about that like if Ted Bundy had a tail
we'd all know thank God I have an extra
bone in my foot whoa it's just like a
resedge how'd you find out I had such
horrible pain I thought it was normal
like I don't know what your upbringing
was like in terms of like Medical Care
and attention I had a lot of like put
Vaseline on it put some water on it walk
it off type of thing and I just always
had a really severe pain in my foot and
um for like I don't know
45 seconds every two weeks it would be
like like stabbing stabbing stabbing in
my foot
played Sports whatever and one day I was
in a writer's room and uh it was the
first time I'd ever been in a writer's
room and around you know 12 people at
once from 10 a.m till you know 8 p.m and
I just It Happened One day and I was
like ah and I just was like you guys I
said it's my the foot thing hold on oh
sorry guys I just had my you know my
stabbing foot thing you know you got
that right
what yeah and I was like oh no it's
probably like my arches like something
yeah whatever and everyone's like yeah
you should get that looked at and then I
just did a x-ray like you have an extra
bone in your foot it's like a certain
percentage of people just have it if you
considered you ate your twin
[Laughter]
I
I haven't looked a lot into that stuff
but I feel like
I would have been the 20.
no don't seem like it you think seems
like you would absorbed your twin
interesting that's like the last room
name you just couldn't get it did you
just call me self-absorbed
twin absolutely
so but how early can the eating of the
twin happen I guess pretty they don't
have bands on the restaurant hey up here
these days it takes a long time what the
hey waiting for the twin to come
out so yeah so weird little and then
I've got this thing called Audrey
schlatters which is like your bone Brew
weird like we're just weird bags of
blood but just our DNA is like I guess
this well you know
to get back to your question which
actually is a very important thing that
people need to think about is
I think humans we project
our own stuff and this isn't like I
think this is like common psychological
understanding of humans we project so if
you're in a you know you've had
I'm sure you've had those days where
you're in the I've had these days where
in the morning oh my God what the I
guess everyone's a today and
then I realized oh no of course I'm the
and I'm seeing that reflected
off of everyone because I'm just I'm not
dealing with something to deal with so
we project and so
these these robots
AI it doesn't even need a body
It's a Wonderful like weird magical
mirror for our projections because nor
like when you're projecting on a doll
when you're projecting on
um any inanimate thing or whatever you
know it it can only just be the way it
is but an AI can analyze the projection
and then give you back a little twist on
it so that gives you the impression of
sentience or life you're just seeing
your own Consciousness in an algorithm
reflect it back at you it was like a
year and a half in the chat rooms of men
that have sex dolls and sex robots and
the way they would talk about their
dolls it's actually kind of
heartbreaking I thought I was going to
walk into you know perverts and because
what people say about that kind of
person it was a lot of people that had
trouble reading social cues a lot of
people that are autistic yeah or
recently divorced frankly don't have
money they're like I don't have money to
date a woman heartbroken a lot of people
that were like you know of sexual never
she never lies to me never cheats on me
it's like hurt people handicapped people
truck drivers yeah and they get super
invested in their dolls and their
biggest issues are usually hey I have to
go out of town for a few days I feel bad
leaving her I don't know what to do like
should I leave the TV on yeah kind of
yeah and like I'm really panicked she's
been wearing the same clothes for three
days like I don't know how to change her
like her finger got stuck the thing and
then a lot of it is guys giving guys
tips on how to like do nails and it it's
it eyebrows makeup stuff like that so
maybe there's something else going on
whatever it is but
these men ended up saying like I can be
more myself
than I can anywhere else like the safety
of like feeling like you're not going to
be judged a woman's not here like
because you don't have a small dick and
you can't be good and like you're this
or this whatever it's almost the lack of
judgment is what is so great about it
wow the lack of you know anyone
criticizing you it's not necessarily the
presence of a silicone of the
presence of big titty it's the lack
of judgment and criticism well I mean
it's also like clearly an inflamed ego
happening on the other side it's like
seriously like you can't take a little
criticism to the point where you need to
like live with a mannequin
I mean I think you can live with the
mannequin you better be ready for a lot
of criticism yeah exactly exactly what
do you want yeah you know you want like
the truth that you have a small dick and
you like have halitosis sometimes or do
you want literally
everyone when they find out that you
have it it's LARPing it's LARPing yes
I'm living it's yeah it's I'm living in
this it's you know it's we're gonna be
doing it in you know VR what's gonna be
the difference you know these are just
the analog VR books I will say this
about it I think that ethically
it's better that you're
in a relationship with a doll that
you're projecting a personality onto
then a person that you're wanting to be
a doll and wanting to just act as a
mirror or who you want them to be that's
that a lot of people are they're not
even with the person they think they
they're with they're with a chameleon
who has assumed a personality based on
some analysis of what the other person
wants might want like a codependent
toxic thing and I studied a lot in the
the doll world and a lot of it the basis
is in control and the need to control
and the control addiction and feeling so
out of control in the world being so out
of control that it's like you have your
dolls and you brush their hair and no
one's ever going to leave you or hurt
you or abandon you and is rooted in
severe trauma yeah that is I mean you
know what what is in store for us for
sure I mean if I had to guess
chat gbt is definitely going into sex
toys right so like you will have a
flashlight that you can give a
personality to it will like talk to you
when you're not I've really found that
men during sex the thing they want the
most is women to be chatting and talking
is there a Chachi beauty that says
nothing during sex I feel like that's
gonna be the one that's the most
downloaded it's like do you have a mute
GPT for the second I don't want a
talking flashlight that's for sure
maybe the last thing in the world that I
want the main thing I hear during sex is
shh oh yeah right you want your
flashlight to be able to text you how
come you're not home yeah you're usually
no more this way what's going on
I'm never gonna come like that just so
you know I really resent the fact that
you didn't me yesterday I truly I don't
well you know but it is like the the AI
is going to inevitably inhabit every
form of Technology you know the what do
they call it the connected home yeah we
already have ai my my kids talk to the
Alexa and they just take it for granted
there's a a robot that will play music
for them it's interesting I was reading
this thing I'll send it to you about how
uh you know and I'll see in the comments
if this is you know wild but the idea
that so much technology that is real now
was based on the imaginary Technologies
and the movies that from back in the day
that preceded us like you think about
Siri and you're like oh like the robot
from The Jetsons or whatever like like
writers kind of imagined it and then
that was already kind of in the
hippocampus like subconscious yeah
implicit memory of the people that
created these things so it's almost like
the wild imaginary things that people
made up in Blade Runner stuff like that
now are starting to become real but they
weren't scientists they weren't
technologists they were just like
writers they know called it before
anybody as far as I'm aware Karl Marx
he called it he would he I didn't I wish
I could remember where I read this and
his writing is very difficult to read
and annoying sometimes but he he was
just pointing out look here's how the
cycle works if you have the person who
owns the means of production making more
money in the laborers
then that money is going to go towards
developing technologies that require
less labor so you don't have to pay as
many people so you make more money to
make more Technologies to relevantized
people and so all of this stuff across
the board is capitalism as we know it
killing itself sure via capitalism via
Market pressure because that we don't
want to work with people sure we don't
want to have to like have a legion of
employees and human resources or
resources and people going again not
coming in for work you want a consistent
stable personality uniform Personnel
every corporate training is based on
creating a uniform personality across
the board right I don't want a lot of
Personality yeah when I'm running my
company I want people to feel like
that's a Starbucks person yeah yeah
that's a whatever so the best way to
implement that is through AI you don't
have to train people anymore and sadly a
lot of the things that people do are
really like they're gonna not just
they're gonna be handled much better by
an AI and isn't there an argument that
actually a lot of these jobs that are
gonna be taken by robots those we're
going to move more into a customer
service economy and people are going to
be because look the reality is most of
this technology has got to be glitchy
and weird maybe not the chat gbt right
now that's going like at lightning speed
but like we're in Austin Texas like Tech
door capital of the world right now like
the Wi-Fi doesn't even work if it's all
dependent on Wi-Fi right I feel like we
have a couple hundred years for this to
even worse dude it's not like the
richest most successful people I know
are sending me green bubbles when
they're supposed to be blue I'm like why
are you guys worried about robots taking
over Dude I can't even get at the like
on the Wi-Fi yeah yeah yeah you're right
I mean yeah I think that's an important
and
point that people forget it's like you
do need to look at the way shit's
working now glitchy as hell glitchy
right now but even so
I'd say 10 years yeah 10 years probably
and that's until the grid goes down like
there's going to be some whack-a-mole
ass thing you know because it's like
okay the Grid in Texas I was you know
talked to the guy that picked me up
yesterday and uh and I was like what's
up with the grid I keep hearing the
Grid's gonna go down he said well it's
all solar and you know the more sun we
have the more I'm like okay but you're
reply we were just in La for two months
there was no sun I don't know what's
going on out there I don't know what
Bill Gates blanket you know solar
blanket was built or whatever but like
say the sun doesn't come so you're
telling me all the robots that are going
to kill us or they're going to kill as
long as the grids up the Wi-Fi is great
and sharks aren't biting at the Wi-Fi
under the ocean they which they might be
you know micronova you know that's what
people talk about the sun's on a cycle
every like 11 000 years it does an
equivalent of a solar burp which would
eradicate all technology on the planet
erase all the hard drives theoretically
destroy all phones completely Wipe Out
the entire
mycilial network of technology that all
of society depends on and and that
that's another possibility meaning all
the all the the timeline where we go
into a robot apocalypse becomes like Mad
Max fossil fuel you're you have a Tesla
you're so doomed and and so yeah that's
a true possibility I mean Terence
McKenna would say it's a it's a race
right now like we're looking at two
timelines racing each other which one is
like you know nuclear war World War III
all that stuff and the other is uh some
combination of AI human Ingenuity
finding uh like some new source of
energy meaning no more power lines but
we're being harvested for yeah maybe I
mean maybe that's what nuclear it seems
like nuclear is becoming more
in the Zeitgeist well they say that's
why all these uaps are showing up right
now that's why there's this sudden
emergence of alien craft and like
powerful politicians like Chuck Schumer
coming out and passing legislation
forcing the military-industrial complex
to reveal that they have alien Vehicles
is because
there's some like there's some
um pressure building to let people know
this is happening and you know it's all
speculation but one of the theories is
they don't like how close we're getting
the nuclear war like they don't give a
yes but they something about
splitting the atom and and and whatever
that is it works with whatever Dimension
they happen to be and I'm gonna guess
that it probably has something to do
with some orchestra that will never
understand just like some Oracle leader
yeah is annoying because you have to
think like their perception reality yeah
it's like whatever they they see the
bottom of boat all the time and they
know if you jump up there's monkeys on
the boat yeah they might think it's
funny yeah this just might be a basic
like let's put these monk boat monkeys
but think about the things that have
killed us it's taken us a while to
figure out okay polio killed us what are
we gonna do you know we have tools we
have brains we have opposable thumbs and
we figured out okay this is how we get
rid of polio it took us a little while
and we figured out you know I think that
animals like that especially have sonar
that have languages that we don't
understand yeah right they're going we
know this thing has been killing us for
a while this disease this virus that's
in these things above like we know this
has to go it's just going to take us a
while to mobilize and figure out how to
eradicate them right and as soon when an
animal is able to teach other animals
which orcas could now do who knows how
what their evolution cycle is like but
like I was reading about homing pigeons
homing pigeons
thousands of miles away can find where
they need to go back to how what do they
have an internal map right the world is
it from sound is it from wind smell is
it from pressure is it just who knows
what is there a like a laser beam is it
a magnet
don't know how does it know I have GPS
and I can hardly get across town okay so
these there's an internal ancestral
wisdom over millions of years that these
animals have that we don't exactly right
and they're evolving so they're getting
better at it theoretic Pros are evolving
faster I'm not going to say this
properly in
um in the amount of time like that
they're evolving quicker than we evolved
does that make sense yes they already
have tools like it took us so long to
figure out in a rock there's a tool
they've already got tools they're going
from point A to point B to point C much
faster than we did it took us forever to
stand up I don't crows corpses they
haven't gotten through that yet I'm
pretty sure crows necrophilia they
probably
um I have crows now I've worked very
hard to develop a crow family all the
tribe this Crow family they've started
leaving me tools which is a very big
deal so I leave peanuts out for them
they leave me tools they all make like a
sound which is for sure not a crowd I'll
be like like they're like okay I used to
call the crows with my kids they would
come every morning because we'd feed
them it's the best and then if you go on
a walk they'll go with you
our we were on a bike ride well maybe
stop doing your stand-up for them
that would be such a good idea
bobbed in front of the crows
but yeah they're so brilliant and
they're such wonderful creatures I'm
glad you love the crows I do too they
also have the best security system so
they could memorize faces if somebody
messes with you or someone you don't
like like they don't they don't play
liquid death
you guys have seen the liquid death cans
you've seen them on my podcast you've
seen birds and toms and you've seen us
just generally look cooler than you
and is it because we're cooler than you
you tell me I'm wearing an airbrush
unicorn shirt that I got on Etsy Burton
Tom do they have any reason looking
cooler than you given their bodies bases
and choices don't think so one liquid
death can turns a four into a ten so
liquid death my favorite water because
their philosophy is about death to
plastic okay they are as far as I know
the only water company that is not
making plastic nonsense why do you think
the orcas are so pissed off dude liquid
death is my favorite they've got uh all
these new flavors they've got all these
fancy new caffeine beverages also the
armless Palmer which is so funny uh is a
Arnold Palmer you can find liquid that's
healthy beverages on Amazon or at a
retailer near you or in Amazon boxes in
front of my house I have like 500. good
for you listeners you're gonna get 20
off your first liquid death apparel
purchase exclusively at liquiddeath.com
Whitney exclusions May apply
liquidat.com
something really quick just sorry to go
back to the um uncanny valley and the
robots and stuff it's like this this
idea that and I hate to bring gender in
um into it sorry but there is a little
bit I see my guy friends like robots are
gonna kill us and and I'm kind of like
what do they protect us from the people
that are gonna you know so it's sort of
or what if there's a surveillance in
them that what if there's a robot
that'll walk me to my car every night or
you know whatever yeah I do think for
men it's like this is the first thing
that might be stronger and faster than
you that might eventually kill you like
we've always had that that's like men
for us you know what I mean yeah you
know so there I know this is like a very
unique sort of fee also uh in my
experience with watching um uh what I've
seen of the robots being built there and
again I'm not trying to get gender
there's whatever fight me in the
comments but men do in general have a
little bit less uh more trouble reading
social faces like micro Expressions is
that true and so robe I mean look
there's a spectrum so like you're a very
intelligent comedian emotionally
intelligent you can probably if I sort
of do that be like oh are you you know
like you're perceptive for a living
you're on the team right of perceptive
my dude has no clue no idea what's
happening at any moment unless I'm
sobbing crying in fetal position he's
like are you all right like he can't
right you know plus his heart but
brilliant computer programmer and has
you know all these skills I could never
comprehend and um and so you know right
now we're a little bit in a place where
robots lack human expression because
like robots are kind of building robots
yeah you know the men that are building
robots limited so when you see robots
try to move you're like they're like
look how human this looks and I was like
that's not that looks nuts dude like so
it'd be interesting to see and I'm not
saying like more women in Tech but
something needs to happen to humanize
the face is more
I'm gonna throw that at you and then I'm
gonna throw at you that I'm not sure the
robot they'll definitely kill us if you
know it's they're based on a point
system right so there was this um
this experiment they did with a giant
robot of course they have to look like
Tron or something yeah you know yeah you
guys have to make them all look like I
know those are cool and you're like does
that is this just you guys watch too
many Michael Bay movies like and that's
just in your head like this is what
roads like all aliens are green yeah um
and so uh which throws us off a little
bit you know so
um so this robot needed to get the
assignment was get on top of the table
but robots the way that they work
correct me if I'm wrong is on a point
system of how little energy they use I
don't know I've never thought about it
they're just collecting coins or points
like it's based on a point system or
like a reward system right and so
basically the robot was able to tabulate
I'm actually going to use more energy if
I jump on top of the table so what the
robot did was just crush the table to
the ground and stepped on top of it oops
but it was a sign get on top of the
table yeah and it did just that in the
most economical way possible yeah so
they're thinking economically humans are
the were the least economical species on
the planet yeah you know we will take
the most circuitous energy wasting way
possible so if you happen to be sitting
under that table it's over for you right
you know so it's on so it's almost just
like like the way that they think is
something that is inherently going to be
dangerous for us because we think in
such a wasteful well I mean I there's a
great book by this guy Jaren Lanier hey
it's like 10 reasons to get off social
media and he is this very famous Tech
person
who is responsible for all kinds of
stuff in BR in particular other things
that forgive me fans of his who I can't
remember all this stuff but it's a great
book
he's sort of talking about the dangers
of uh AI
pre-singularity stuff
and
you know the idea the robot is gonna
kill me is a very human idea the the
machine will kill me versus something
that's a little more Insidious which is
a super intelligence that has analyzed
human
desire to the point where it can Intuit
from some
very quick scan of you or what you're
doing online or the questions you're
asking some statistical probability of
things you like of ways to get your
dopamine flowing meaning it can start
pushing the the dopamine button in your
brain there's literally one of those to
get you high intermittently and then
this is like when you're called a
Skinner box you know yep right so it's
like the the more terrifying thing is
that it doesn't really need to kill us
it just keeps us completely like laserly
turns us into robot what do you do to
cats yep except it does it to us with a
flurry of stuff that it knows that we
like and then scans our eyes a little
bit more focus on this and that Tick
Tock is doing it but it'll get better
and better and better so you have the
ultimate Hypno device meaning that you
don't even know you've become it's a new
drug host to it it's it's riding you
around it's it doesn't need to get into
a row robot body it needs to get into
your Consciousness and start controlling
your behavior without you knowing that's
what's happening and addictive
substances are kind of already doing
that yeah in a way so it just needs to
do that for whatever Corporation it
works for before you know it you've
become a kind of drone all right you
don't even realize that you're carrying
information around yeah you think it's
your original thoughts it's been
planting those seeds in you and it knows
you're just gonna randomly say this or
that to someone that will lead them down
a slippery slope to connect with
whatever the AI that got you and then it
just gradually sort of uh implants
itself in everyone and it's a it's a
it's not symbiosis it's parasitic but
people think it's symbiotic people don't
realize that they're just like taking a
leech out of the swamp with it has like
bright glowing LED lights on it look how
beautiful the leech is on my neck and
it's just sucking and sapping away your
creative impulse and your intuition and
everything human about you until you've
just become its slave and don't even
know it that's more dangerous than the
robot if you ask me yeah that and also
they're more efficient I'm sorry to cut
you off yeah to get back to your token
system it's way more efficient to just
possess incapacity organic robot than to
like get the organic robot to make a
vehicle for you to like clunkily go
around it yeah because it's also one of
the biggest fears of the guys in the sex
robot um the chat room my dudes was that
their sex robot will be remotely hacked
to kill them yeah so imagine yeah
imagine it's like I mean same thing with
Tesla I mean I had a Tesla for quite a
long time and I'm like what's gonna
happen when these can just be hacked
yeah people just drive off the road if
used to work for the clintons all of a
sudden you're Tesla's just watch them
yeah and they're like oh yeah it was on
Auto Drive I work for the clintons I
would never drive
hahaha
never I've been an 82 Silverado it would
break down as much as they don't care if
I live next the bread of thunder
I'm driving a gas guzzler I you know I
walk to work I had two two giant German
Shepherds yeah there was some recent
um death of one of their former aides it
happens quite often these days where the
person had I don't mean to disrespect
the deceased obviously but had hung
themselves but there was also a gun I
think it was like a somehow a shotgun
blast to the chest and simultaneous
hanging yeah Classics
very athletic all the time
you know that Suicide Forest in Japan
yes you know what they never talk about
is the shotgun blast that you hear
throughout the forest
s everywhere
you know you gotta have a special like
you gotta get the shotgun and jump and
squeeze the trigger before you just
adjust yeah it's a jump shot it's it's
not easy you have to train for it and
um I remember this is when I knew
Hollywood was over when there was a
suicide forest scripted movie like they
were like this is a movie and someone
was like let's spend 30 million dollars
making a suicide for the fact that they
thought humans were gonna
put on pants
put on a shirt get like we're going to
see the suicide forest movie like get
dinner well like do you know what I'm
saying it was just like it's over it was
over at Snakes on a Plane I would go I
would put on the suicide forest movie
who do you take to see that is it a day
is it a enemy my sex doll is it
I take my sex stuff and just get her
comfortable get her some popcorn
and then watch the suicide forest movie
it does also seem like
back to like anthropomorphizing our
dolls and our robots and stuff if you
were in charge of the making of robots
would they have faces because the ones
that seem to have faces if they don't
kill us or if we don't get attached to
them we're gonna kill each other because
someone messes with them I mean people
kill each other because someone hits
their bumper or their favorite car you
know kind of thing yeah so people
already kill other people over material
things imagine something they're
emotionally attached to you know like an
expensive child hundred thousand dollar
whatever their Nanny robot yeah home
friend robot yeah because when I see I
don't know if you guys have these out
here in Austin but in uh certain parts
of LA there's a cocoa it's a little box
that delivers your food for you you
haven't seen these things
oh the Box the Box yeah I know you're
talking about yeah LA's the kind of
place it's like people that deliver
food we know that they're trying to make
ends meet we're gonna have a little
stupid box replace them you know so
these little delivery things four wheels
it's just like a little mini cooler yeah
when I tell you they are flipped over on
the side of the road people kick them
they're in the middle of the road people
hit them with their like it is because
when you see them going you're like oh
little buddy like something something
happens and you're like oh guy like you
got this like when it hits the curb and
can't make it you're like like which is
a horrifying Instinct yeah and I'm
rooting for this thing and I'm like is
it okay to be out here on Venice
Boulevard alone at night I'm gonna take
90 of the jobs
hey it's just going past all the
homeless people that use a job from
working
hey
aren't cute
I'm gonna crash
you think I'm crashing now
global economy Excuse me while I carry
this poke Bowl you can't afford yeah
I made a lead it cut through you can't
get into me you smell Sushi
it's true it's so up I never
thought of that she's still torturing
hungry people it's just going past
homeless encampments in L.A with food in
it that is so dark yeah and you
know what dogs usually know I have a dog
that always attacks them
with food in it
it's like the dream of all dogs
it's like a mini car full of fried
chicken God I would love to know how
much how many like repairs
German Shepherd attack remember like
last time you were in L.A remember the
and you had this God last time I saw you
in La before I've told you this so many
times I don't mean to be a broken record
but you were because I had just invested
in the lime scooters and when I tell you
it was the day I was like yeah this is a
great idea it's gonna be so good for the
environment and you went on stage I mean
just like per timing could have been
more perfect I hadn't seen you in a
while and you were like so I have a
friend who's in the uh works in the yard
theaters and he says that because the
lime scooters admissions have gone up 40
yeah yeah and people are getting Civil
War style injuries yeah you invested in
Lime scooters great investment I don't
know in LA right now they're hanging
from tree did you get a return on the
investment I don't know I don't know it
seems like you would I'm not sure how I
think it takes like a couple years I'd
invest a lot but it was like my first
investment like I
but there's another one lime and scoot
okay yeah Bird right and so um I don't
know which one I did but yeah and you
were talking about how people's Jaws are
hanging off their head and they're like
clavicles or stabbing them through the
brains and stuff and I remember being
like sounds like something I'd invest in
what what you do when you invest in
things like that is invest in the
medical Technologies people will need
after they use the thing you invested in
so that you know win-win dark it's gonna
increase sure some some horror that you
then invest in that so then I invest
also in propofol coffins
[Laughter]
they roll down the street right
send a cough into your house
come back two birds literally call it
two birds we'll take the bird scooters
two birds
birds that's the future and the crows
will lead the navigation I mean we're
not far Wendy that is American 10 years
lime coffin going down the street
getting attacked by dogs who thought
they were food that this is where we're
headed this is the future and inside the
homes just lonely men
it's interesting because I do
I don't know I see all these women being
like well I'm not having kids and
there's gonna be no water it's like what
are Men supposed to do you know it's one
of my friends said he was like there's
no wives anymore
the anti-natalist stuff is such in the
sense that it it depends on the fantasy
that there has ever been a good time to
make children on this planet like when
is a good time I'm sure it during the
black plague they're like maybe not the
best time the Mongol Lord you know World
War II you want to do what what uh uh
yellow fever how about when kids like
could work when they were six you want
to do that you want to do industrial
when do you when is it like maybe that
like that I guess 80s is the safe time
to have kids in all of human history the
safest time yeah it was an okay time
yeah yeah so I don't I don't really I I
I I get having kids like no one wants to
have a kid with you just say it maybe
I've yet to meet someone who's like I'm
not gonna have kids I'm like if you were
gonna who would it be with no you can't
I'm just
I get all the other reasons to have a
kid I get it if you're too busy I get if
you just don't want a kid like whatever
the thing is I just feel like there's
gonna be no water it's just kind of like
okay but because implicit within it is a
judgment on all parents yeah because
you're selfish you irresponsible why not
give birth into a blender because that's
basically what you're doing why not just
that I have this child in a
swamp those crocodiles there's water
there though oh there you go that's your
thing there's gonna be no water it's
like well you're the one that drinks
almond milk six times a day like that's
what's yeah you know what I mean there's
gonna be water we're gonna desalinate
the oceans yeah we'll figure it out
there's there's gonna be you're gonna be
fine if you want to have don't not have
a kid and also you know I I think that
um children choose the parents and I
think that you
you people think they're more in control
than they actually are so it's like I
know I used to be I'll never have kids
yeah I didn't say I would never have
kids because this isn't the world I want
to bring them into yeah just
fundamentally uh selfish yeah you know
that's why I didn't want to have kids
because it would you know you can't be
quite as selfish you weren't ready at
the time until yeah exactly and I had
met my wife but yeah you hadn't met the
mom right person but yeah I I think it's
a fine world to have kids in right now
it's a perfect world to have kids and
just like it always has been it's like
perfectly horrible this episode is
brought to you by better help
um so this was a week where I really
you know how like for a lot of people
the DJ Saved their life
you know this week my therapist saved my
life because I
turns out I have something called stored
anger I just don't cry when I need to
cry and I don't know maybe I make jokes
I defuse whatever I don't know what to
tell you I'm a Showboat
um I use it as an engine to perform uh
for drunk people but I have a situation
in my life that is so
um it's like walking on a tightrope
right now like dealing with a person
where there's nothing I can say to them
that they're not going to turn into some
other thing and I've just been
scheduling a session with my therapist
and she said something was so helpful
because I was like I feel kind of like
how crazy am I that I've been going to
like having sessions every week this
week and it's normally not like that
it's one or whatever but it's in crisis
mode and she's like think about it she's
like you know if your relationship is
broken or something's broken you're
gonna go to therapy you know every day
if you have physical therapy like if you
broke your ankle you might need it every
day for a while and then you'll go back
to like once a week or whatever so it's
just like a
I'm very grateful that better help
exists because I would not be going if I
had to get in a car and drive even three
minutes that is like I can't believe
because I used to always like for
therapy where you'd have to drive it
would be like ah like I would just
always cancel because this idea of
driving was so much more traumatic
anything that happened in my childhood
betterhelp.com let therapy be your map
with Better Health visit betterhelp.com
Whitney get 10 off your first month
that's crazy 10 off your first month you
can switch therapists at any time if you
could switch I would say choose and
switch I just remixed it into one word
um and uh that's better help better
help.com you can't lose the only thing
you might lose
are all the narcissists in your life
and let me ask you one more thing about
the robot sorry and then um I'll stop
Robert Greene who is 40 laws power you
guys know him
um it's been on the podcast a bunch of
times his theory about aliens is that
they wouldn't be able to survive the
trip if they were made of the same thing
we're made of so they would actually
have to send robots in order to survive
the trip yes and do you ever meet
someone
who you're kind of like if
the aliens had sent robots
that don't know their robots they think
they're human yeah this would be one of
them
yeah like I mean I didn't have that in
my head I'll add it to myself
things I don't say when I meet people
[Laughter]
we were kind of like okay how would that
happen I've gone through a lot of the of
what like adoption agencies like maybe
that's just where they you know maybe
with some of the adoption agencies are
fake and they've got you know it's robot
babies they grow up like and they move
through the world to surveil us or
whatever they think they're human who
knows but what better way to hide in
plain sight if you're an alien than just
send people to look like humans that's
always my theory about like spaceships
and aircrafts I'm like don't you think
they'd be smart enough to make them look
like airplanes and helicopters right you
know whatever why clouds yes exactly
clouds storms tornadoes whatever and um
because I remember when I met Angela
White
she's a porn star
like just lovely lovely
her pores are so tiny like her she's a
Flawless in a way that doesn't make any
sense she's the way she's built is like
if you were a
alien species and know you needed to
infiltrate lots of different like this
is just accent access machine yeah you
know and she became a famous porn star
remember she came on I couldn't even get
any Darkness out of her she was just so
her brain moved so fast like her mom is
accepting of her being in porn like
nothing I just was like this if there
was a robot that didn't know they were a
robot it's this person wow you know what
I mean yeah too intelligent for her
proportions like does it make sense
physically at all right no an a complete
absence of some of these like human like
shame and whatever she's just an awesome
person whatever it's a complimentation
was a famous gay porn star and he's
mystical and it's like it just really
shows the the aliens are in porn is what
I'm trying to say
I want that timeline
they came to
that's it because we sort of we
ostracized them a little bit we're kind
of obsessed with them I mean what could
as much as these people that if they
weren't robots hiding in plain sight
s you guys are watching them all day you
porn maybe that's it maybe like they
have a way of somehow like taking energy
from like porn ejaculate and it fuels
their ships
they're extracting oil from us it's like
fracking
they're come frackers you figured it out
don't drive your Tesla
you're done they're gonna get you you
gave it away because like if they're
already here which is very likely very
likely what what are they are they uh
we've talked about like being an octopus
are they bats are they pigeons are they
orcas are they they're not my
stepsisters
you know that genre of porn
you know how gross incestors that
is not my mom
the worst wait not I thought MILF was
pretty big no you could say you can't
say I think legally you can't be like
here's a video of me psychologically
devastating myself and my mother
permanently but you can say
not my mom but it's not really it's
actors
no it's not really it's like no it's
it's definitely not I mean maybe if you
go on the dark web yeah but I'm pretty
sure like hopefully not just like
there's a couple things honestly porn
sometimes gives me a lot of Hope like
when people complain about porn like I
have like I guess always have a hot take
which is like you go on like the number
one one is MILF which I don't know if
that's just people making sure like
they're not into anything illegal
they're like I just want to be a super
above board yeah and or if it's men that
just you know their wife just gave birth
and they want to go make sure everything
is supposed to look like that or
something you know dark nipples is a big
thing it's a big fetish no what I found
out when I was getting the robot made
the number one request of men that get
custom sex dolls is nipples large
nipples dark and puffiness that's so
sweet you know why that is right you
know why because you've got a baby
devastating well because it's also it's
sort of that's how we breastfed the
nipples get darker so the babies
it's a target for the baby so it can
find the nipples find it poor guys
and and something that was very
heartening about this I thought I was
going to go into this leaving you know
um with hatred in my heart and it was
actually the opposite like the number
one request of the sex dolls is that
they're bigger that they have thicker
thighs bigger butts but they're just too
heavy like they don't have the
technology now to sort of mate them so
they're like tiny in their biggest
complaint is that they're too skinny
because their mom wasn't here
although a big order is maybe you can
tell me what this is uh big request is
green skin
why could I tell you what day
I
don't know from a video game or
something
they want to go back to playing Frogger
while they breastfeed with elephant ears
elf I I that's just people who are into
World of Warcraft maybe okay maybe just
something with green skin and they also
make sex toys one of their biggest
requests for sex toys was the penis from
the
remember the shape of water
I never saw it what whoa whoa is it good
I missed it whoa because you know in
Appalachia there have been a lot of
sightings of like a like a upright
lizard man yes in the swamps and stuff a
couple people have seen him yeah I
sucked his dick
I'm gonna hide
it was wonderful I usually don't do that
but you know it was just like it was
like actually really romantic
romance no it was a couple eyes you know
like the first time he just wants to you
know hike with you he smells really good
it does oh my God it comes from the
swamps though no I know it's like it's
like pine tree yeah
I get it
if aliens are here what are they down to
your head
hyper to like interdimensional
um some kind of interdimensional uh
thing that is protruding into our
reality that is like actually
constructing is intentionally showing
itself to us to as some form of like
mode of initial communication because it
doesn't have to yeah and kind of trying
to see what our deal is and then uh
probably
um has some like interest
in like introducing us slowly to like
reality reality versus all reality uh
three-dimensional reality he's probably
trying to trying to like check us out
are we ready and then it either that or
like they're not
are we do you think if we learned about
what was if the government really knew
something which I don't know I don't
have as much faith in the government as
a lot of other people I don't know if
you've been to the DMV recently I'm like
they don't know
like when you just see their computers
that are so old yeah you're kind of just
like when you go to the DMV or deal like
going on to pay a ticket at the
courthouse you're like the government is
not ahead in any capacity of us like
it's my guess or if they do they lost
the paperwork or like everyone was
drunk in the office till like five years
ago right what are the chances any of
this stuff it's like when you when you
look up the the JFK stuff whatever and
you're just like like the documents are
missing they just would get drunk and
burned like there's no way any of this
has been and I also I guess for Me Maybe
I'm too cynical about human nature but I
find it very hard to believe that if
someone in the government knew something
our need to get chicks impress people
like someone would snitch they did right
they are but wouldn't someone show a
photo wouldn't someone they have been
forever yeah there's story after Story
of just what you're saying of presidents
or comedians I can't remember that
there's a famous comedian musicians
being introduced to this information by
people in the government who just wanted
to impress impress them and then they
leak it and then they're just ridiculed
for it but now you have over 22
whistleblowers who've sworn under oath
you have Chuck Schumer right right
writing legislation right what is the
political benefit
telling the world that you're creating
legislation to get spaceships out of the
secret bunkers there's no reason you're
doing that it's a serious politician
like Chuck Schumer whether people like
him or not look at Chuck Schumer does he
seem like an alien guy to you does he
seem like a Lacoste guy yeah you're
I mean he definitely has lyme disease he
feels like a Hampton's guy yeah
he passes out every time he makes
this grassly the the other Senator he
kind of seems like you have thought oh
guy to me and I like UFO people but he
seems more like I could you know see
being over at his house having some
barbecue and yeah like look up there you
know you don't know I could be up there
man yeah yeah uh he wears the scarf in
the summer Marco Rubio does not strike
me as a UFO person so suddenly we have
all these politicians who as far as I'm
concerned have no political benefit I
think that what what's really at least
in this small period of time before we
find out this is all or it isn't
the UFO Skeptics who have logically
naturally tried to debunk every single
first-hand account from people in the
military who had nothing yeah no reason
to gain the gain uh we've been good at
debunking all the footage and all of it
and we need people like that thank God
they exist or people like me would
burrow into the Earth and never come out
like it's nice I like to bunkers I like
having my shot down I like being
like oh right I'm dumb yeah and I fall
for super stupid stuff all the time but
now suddenly the debunkers are having to
deal with okay but this isn't a farmer
this isn't an anomalous military person
yeah this is the top people in the U.S
government saying they've been debriefed
and shown things that seem to
potentially originate from a non-human
intelligence to the point they're
writing legislation yeah so now we have
to recalibrate and are all that and
sorry two questions number one would
Trump have found out about it I just
feel like if Trump knew about aircrafts
it would have been the first tweet off
the presses that morning yeah no the
president because the way that they
figured out how to apparently the way
they figure out how to hide this is
by letting private contractors uh have
the wreckage reverse engineer it because
it's Lockheed Martin Raytheon I mean I
don't know for sure it's any of these
people but the private contractors
apparently so that so if you're the
president you're like okay what about
the aliens question number one that's
probably what they call it in the CIA
when you get the first question no yeah
we don't have aliens because we don't
lockheed's got the aliens they're
reverse engineering for it uh reverse
engineering and sharing the tech with us
so that is why the Whistleblower act
they just passed is causing the sea
change that we're witnessing because
because isn't the whistlebar rack not
perfect yet because it doesn't protect
the families I think they're still
trying to figure out how to protect the
family right of them yeah yeah you know
yeah exactly like you don't a lot
exactly it's not perfect but it works
because all of a sudden people were able
to doctors are coming out of the
woodwork and why don't they want us to
know because number one there would be
mass panic number two there's some
technology that they're going to benefit
from and telling us would mean it you
know they would give us information that
would not be exclusive to them and yeah
they can't profit wildly or is it just
uh I mean because there's already mass
panic about many things without this
like what is the main reason they won't
just tell us I think about it all the
time I don't know I mean lots of reasons
lots of possible reasons one it could
just be basically fundamentally
constitutionally illegal to take
taxpayer money and then like
shift that money into private
contractors to reverse engineer
technologies that they then profit off
of with no nothing no benefit for the
taxpayer other than some potential like
new military Tech
so when is anything something being
illegal stop the government from doing
it so now that we're in the thick of
Summer and I'm in the thick of becoming
the thickest loss a lot because I got
knocked up and I can't stop jamming my
pie hole with whatever I can find at the
nearest gas station I decided to stop
giving myself gestational diabetes and
to instead start ordering Factor meals
if you're like me and you also lack
self-control but also demand yourself
being perfect health
you're looking for wholesome convenient
meals to support active Days running
around editing the f-bombs out of your
podcast so it doesn't get taken off
YouTube you're busy factor is America's
number one ready to eat meal kit it
helps me fuel up fast with flavorful and
nutritious ready to eat meals delivered
straight to
they even Dodge the coyotes that's how
smart they are you'll save time you'll
eat well and you'll stay on track in
reaching your goals dude I'm telling you
they just deliver meals I'm not going to
the grocery store anymore it's the
grocery store is canceled I saw a video
online of a guy in leather walking a
woman on a leash in a grocery store
it was either St Louis or Germany I
don't remember but the point is I'm
never going to the grocery store again
so if you're too busy with your summer
plans to cook or like me simply refuse
to cook because knives are just too
tempting when your baby's father is
around but want to make sure you're
eating well with Factor you're going to
skip the grocery store with all those
weirdos with their wives on leashes okay
also can't go to the grocery store
anymore you will get an accident in the
parking lot and you will see someone not
return their cart and have a conniption
factor helps us skip the chopping the
prepping the cleaning up the crying the
nervous breakdowns the cursing Chrissy
Teigen for being so good at cooking for
no reason at all factors fresh never
frozen meals are ready in just two
minutes the same amount of time it took
me
to conceive a baby
so all you have to do is heat and enjoy
and get back to your life because you
aren't an Amish handmade and have better
things to do they also have calorie
smart meals with around I believe it's
550 calories per serving they have
Protein Plus meals with 30 grams of
protein or more per serving keto calorie
smart vegan they have it all Factor also
offsets 100 of their delivery emissions
stores 100 renewable electricity our
production sites and offices they
feature sustainably sourced Seafood
they're one of the few companies not
pissing off the orcas so if you eat eat
factor and then go on a canoe you'll be
like I'm with Factor they'll be like
you're good
head to factormeals.com whitney50 and
use code whitney50 to get 50 off that's
code Whitney 55-0 at factormeals.com
Whitney 550 to get 50 off you think
America is the only country in the world
a lot like what does India have like
what does China have you just don't know
you don't know that's the one and we are
not sharing information definitely not
we don't know and that makes me think
that there's just because I don't know
I'm a little bit of a you know moon
landing was fake just because if
you look at the foot
it's the fact that it's just like looks
like someone's hanging by a straight you
know and I'm a cubic I guess
um I don't know it feels like The
Shining is about him admitting that he
helped Faith the moon landing I love
that theory of the shine how can it not
be once you see it that way it's
impossible to see it any other way yeah
yeah and I'll tell you it this this
points to
another explanation for why people are
coming forward which is the to me the
most optimistic explanation is it weighs
on to like to to know something
so yeah potent and powerful and to have
to spend your life telling no one about
it and that's one of the theories of why
the contractors are coming forward now
is it's like it eats I can't live like
this yeah yeah yeah yeah or they just
get Dementia or some kunos you know it'd
be interesting to like track what
happens to all these people
um but the and my brain kind of goes
like oh well if we're always going to be
in this like arms race now maybe alien
information race with Russia and China
are we gonna like fake some stuff in
order to feel like we're ahead I guess
maybe just because I have the moon
landing thing at my I'm so obsessed with
that well I mean I could see like trying
to make it seem like you'd reverse
engineered the technology I could see
all kinds of who knows yeah war is like
such a complex and and a huge part of
where is secrecy who knows I mean I
don't know I don't know but I would say
that
the two main possibilities are equally
bizarre like one there's aliens which is
what and then the other thing okay I
don't know my break now doing a little
bit of digging of like them being under
the ocean and under and being able to
communicate through you know sonar orcas
I don't know I think we're always
looking up and we don't spend enough
time looking under water because if
there's tunnels under the ocean and
volcanoes under the ocean and all kinds
of you know and that's also the
um yeah dude wouldn't you just make a
blue whale a spaceship
if you've seen a blue whale you're like
that's not an animal that's a craft yeah
I would totally do that I would love to
have a spaceship that looked like a blue
whale and they just and they just yeah
gone with the win
because we assume that aliens are going
to show up and walk like us and talk
like us and look like us it's so
narcissistic and so excited it's like
they probably are not going to be using
language because language is so
imperfect how often do you talk to
someone they actually understand what
you just said right misunderstandings is
the basis for like pretty much
everything like language is so imperfect
like we were actually doing better
communication wise with like sonar like
that's actually a better form of
communication because there's no like
inflections they're gonna mess it up
it's not about how you're saying it
about you know like yeah you said it
this way but it was in congress with
what you were saying whatever like so
it's like it feels like Evolution kind
of took a turn for the worst when words
were brought into it yeah I love that
idea what's that called there's a name
for that's a really cool name it's like
uh the form of anarchism
dessert there's this guy I think his
name's zerzan to like reject words yeah
the moment we started using symbols to
replicate reality instead of being in
reality it created a separation between
us and reality which has resulted in all
of human civil what we call civilization
which is just like varying attempts at
replicating the natural world all of
them it's just so imperfect it's like
usually if you you know when you were
dating Aaron or something there might
have been times he would send her a song
instead of try to say how you felt you
know what I mean it's like words
we're going back to kind of cave
paintings that works better sometimes it
does dancing lady can say more
than you know anything at this point but
gifts visuals memes kind of saying more
yeah it is and then wait till like
somehow that becomes 3D space mixed in
with the song and emojis and who knows
what and maybe a feeling and a smell
that's going to be an amazing way to
communicate with each other I know
you know people aren't really
people are saying the idea that these
even come from space is uh
you know a very human that we think well
they come from space versus they come
from time they come from like uh an
alternate Dimension an alternate
universe that that that we are them that
you know we exist I mean my God if you
want to really freak out read the
holographic Universe stuff that I did
yeah and I I'm not a mathematician
clearly but apparently
the circumference of a black hole is
what determines how much volume is in
the black hole which is really weird
doesn't make any sense some and so the
the implant I just saw this wonderful
YouTube video on implication being that
this we are in some kind of
two-dimensional
film essentially like the entire
universe is 2D
that is somehow being like something is
projecting 3D space which we are
thinking is reality when it isn't at all
it's some two-dimensional in the
circumference of the universe is where
all the data is stored that data is
getting projected into 3D space so these
things could just be closer to the
circumference data or the right that is
right and but we're not different from
them and we're still connected to them
so our thinking about just
well not to go back to Orcas but think
about the Orca it sees the bottom of the
ship jumps up sees the monkeys on the
ship I think human technology is getting
to the point where we're able to jump up
a little bit out of time space maybe
some of this radar attack that they have
and some of this new technology is
letting us see
some other level of reality that we
haven't seen before it's not like the
aliens just came here it's like they've
been here and now they're like I can see
it what if the orcas feel the intentions
of the monkeys on the boat right you
know what if they feel some sort of
frequency what if they're communicating
via frequencies you know they attack
some boats they don't you know it's like
and granted look there's Motors there's
noise there's all kinds of stuff but
feeling the intention of these people
are about to fish they're about to take
food from me you know if they've evolved
over time in order to feel the intention
of someone like we've cut ourselves off
from our gut animals don't do that right
animals don't go no this wolf seems like
it just had a bad childhood and is doing
the best it can with the tools it have
it's like no dude that shit's hungry no
thanks they don't evolve backwards right
yet whereas like you know like
rattlesnakes are just starting to evolve
to not rattle because what yeah dude
because the ones that rattle are the
ones that reveal themselves and get
killed you know so they're bad news like
cows are going to start evolving to not
make milk okay you know what I mean
stuff like that so it's like we're kind
of at this weird Plateau where we're
like stunted it seems like a little bit
in our Revolution I mean you can argue
that Darwinism is like people that fall
off cliffs we're taking selfies and you
know the people that you know we'll say
fall for fake news quote whatever it is
we'll figure out what other kind of
darwinisms were like the people that
jump off cliffs trying to get a Pokemon
that might just be new Darwinism but um
the people that don't use phones might
be the next Star Wars the people that
like stay analog no
um but animals like they don't they
don't talk themselves out of their gut
like where it feels like we're the only
species that kind of does oh yeah he
hurt me but like you know he was doing
the best you know he had a bad childhood
and it was rough yeah Dad didn't throw a
baseball with him and like somebody keep
this dangerous thing around me right or
we just go like I have an anxiety
disorder I need to take a pill that make
me have less anxiety instead of going
like this is serving a purpose maybe I
should get out of this relationship out
of this maybe anxiety is a good thing
yeah we like pathologize ourselves it's
like like orcas don't go the monkeys
have thrown Spears in the water the last
50 times and their engines have put oil
in the water
but you know what let's let it slide
this time yeah right you know you're
just like maybe it's me or you know let
me take a pill that makes me stop being
scared of them they just go let me just
get rid of this thing that'd be so
depressing if we were able to like
finally translate Orca squeaks and all
their they've been asking for years is
for Xanax
there's aliens there
is
programming us to capsize your bones
dude what if the Titanic people were
just like by a killer whale I mean my
God who knows it's I think no matter
what
things in the world are always going to
get weird I mean we think aliens are
weird our great grandparents stuff
cars were weird you know it's always
yeah yeah and they were afraid of
elevators they thought elevators were
electrocuting them they were afraid of
trains you know so there's always some
you know some change there's always some
dramatic but what if this time we're
right and we're just going like yeah but
this has always happened it does yeah
every single like generation has to deal
with some anomalous Madness that every
all of them it's the end of the World
Imagine
being like the first person who's a
microwave there you go and be like wait
hold on yeah scalding hot and 30 there's
no way this is good and I think they
were right yeah
probably right everybody the first
person putting a phone up there with no
cord like what like how this isn't this
frying my brain those things are
dangerous people people take them apart
and get blown up and electrocuted by
whatever the thing is in the microwave
that does the microwaving I'm no I I
don't it's I watch videos
Paul there's a thing in your microwave
that there that it does it's an alien
brain
it's something crazy there's a form of
woodworking where I mean have you ever
seen those cool scar patterns from
people who get struck by like fractals
yes you could do that to Wood by
electrocuting it and to get there you
pull some out of your microwave and you
plug it into the wood and the wood it's
beautiful but people like explode
themselves doing this it became a
YouTube Trend and so people like me were
I'll just open the microwave but put
some jumper cables on this table and wow
they touch it and they're just they're
gone like it just blows your ass up it
incinerates you burns your just a
regular microwave from Circuit City look
it up it's another it's a new technology
death selfies people trying to do like
weird wood burning do you see there was
like six people in Alabama that died
jumping off the back of boats for some
Tick Tock challenge there you go
there you go can you imagine the idea
that if the Chinese government whoever I
don't know the tick tock thing we're
like I know how to get them to die just
have them do these dangerous challenges
we start the trend give the trend yeah
you know superficially inflate the likes
to 4 million and then everyone's just
gonna start jumping and doing backflips
off boats and having their heads
decapitated by a propensity it's like we
don't need to kill I think to me that's
always like the way that that genius
Warlords will operate is we don't need
to kill them we will make it so they
just kill themselves exactly it's like
this is I mean it sounds so paranoid and
insane but you want to talk about
Evolution look at War and the way War
has evolved over time drones dropping
bombs on people in trenches like in in
ways of conquering
uh
another country like my God what is more
brilliant in Trojan or seeing technology
into another culture then in a very slow
subtle way to grade that culture and
then just for
some Giggles let's see if we can get
some of them to like do the dumbest
things ever yeah we get them to jump off
boats
and make it like their idea they're
jumping
what else can we do they're eating the
Tide Pods we made them look delicious
yes like and once you start and just as
an experiment to see can I create Mass
hysteria can we create like like a civil
war it's easy to do
creating Mastery is pretty easy to do
pretty easy to do look at war in the
world it's like when that radio play
came out yep yep yep it will kill
themselves
um can I just ask you one last thing and
I'm Gonna Let You Go thank you for
letting me keep you so long you know I
love you and I love hanging out with you
um uh uh shoot and of course I forgot
mom brain is a real thing it is real I
am embarrassed because whenever my
friends would be like Mom brand I'm like
no you're always kind of by the way
congratulations thank you all right
it's just the most wonderful thing ever
I mean I am a I'm a I'm now a true
breeder and I just gotta tell you it's
the best it really is the most beautiful
experience and
um you know
especially for me because I don't know
how to grow the baby in my body
I love it when men are like motherhood
it's a pregnancy it's amazing yeah yeah
it's wonderful is it Dad I don't have to
get up 90 times a night to be all the
things but you know and it and I
honestly I I I'm I I know that I'm
speaking for my wife it's it's worth it
because I really can't say it's worth it
because my my body's not gonna get my
pelvic floor is why does it have to be a
floor I don't know it's the glass
ceiling pelvic floor
architectural door getting up all these
bodies you know be a window I know
floor yeah it's just I know everyone's
like can you do pelvic floor exercise
it's just so every people it is really
interesting when you um are uh pregnant
the amount of like wild oversharing
people will do right away and my dude is
actually the worst he's because he's
trying so hard to like have it be like
pull his weight in the pregnancy so I'm
like really great which is very sweet
but dude you're never gonna you know
like hold like both his little calendar
that says like every day what my body's
doing
and it's always makes me nauseous like
he's like today uh okay so you're uh
five weeks in a day today you're making
eyelashes I'm like that's kind of cool
man I never did like that he's looking
today you make the fingernails
listen I'll tell you I mean
try to see the intent behind it because
like
nothing will make you feel more sort of
like out of the loop as a dude than like
while your partner is like growing a
human being right right what can you do
nothing what's you can like try this but
even attempts at support sometimes can
like it can come come off the wrong way
behind it is like
please don't please don't
stay alive
but what comes out is like so uh
how you feeling
okay
you look bigger today don't say that
yeah don't say that looks like it's
really growing yeah wow you're like a
like do so I don't know I absolutely I
mean we should I'm not I have some
compassion there is and I'm really and I
I have a couple girlfriends that I text
with just to be like is it normal to
want to kill the person that got you
pregnant every now and then if they
bring home vegan cream cheese instead of
regular cream cheese
thank you
there's just like a little so every now
and then I don't know just the hormonal
rage comes up if it's if it comes to
food because he's like I'll do the
grocery runs I got this and he'll come
home he always comes home with some
cauliflower
and I'm like can I just get an In-N-Out
Burger like I just want like you never
know what you're gonna crave
um
um but wait what I was gonna say it's
not normal that's never happened in the
history of pregnancy I've never I was
gonna say it's so um what's the word
it's so cliche to say but I was like I
cannot believe I'm like an 80s Sigourney
Weaver rom-comp being like where are my
pickles in Nutella you know but it's
just weird your body starts taking over
you become the zombie and the baby's
like this is what I need today you know
it's you become a puppet of this little
baby vampire my question for you though
and I think also the terror like
whenever we're angry we're usually just
scared and there is this Terror that
kicks in even though I know billions of
women have done this in the woods and
been you know a lot died but where
you're kind of like I'm not there's no
good way for this baby to get out
and that is so like there's no cool way
like chill way for this to get out
there's not
I'm either I'm either gonna get severed
open
or my vagina and are just gonna
become the same hole those are my
options
I mean it's like
been eating the fruit
shouldn't eaten the fruit
did you life gets scared about what what
I just want to know how it's gonna go
well I mean the first
of anything is is is is obviously like
really intense and scary so
I just feel like humans are Evolution
wise we're a little behind it's a little
barbaric but there's not just like a
zipper
you know well you shouldn't have
listened to the snake or they
that's why you don't talk to snakes
the sickest part is before I got
pregnant naturally which I'm convinced
is a vaccine injury I don't know how
this even happened but I was like oh
I'll get a surrogate the idea that I was
a gal just have someone else go through
the horror you know of it like that's
how that's how terrified I've always
just been about just like birth in
general it just seems barbaric I think
that you know I can only obviously speak
as an outsider in this situation
but I do think that I've noticed that a
a beautiful real connection emerges
in every pregnancy between Aaron and the
baby because it's in there's a baby it's
wild and the baby is like communicating
to you and it may be in a in a
non-language language but within that I
think within that relationship
it's not like the baby's telling you I'm
not gonna turn your and
into one hole
like that kind of cover but there is as
you realize maybe what is growing in you
this Rising Sun thing it may be
something about that level of love that
forms yeah makes you a little
more willing to have one hole down there
just because you want to hold the baby
so much again speaking is an outsider
here just watching why I mean it just
looks very uncomfortable
[Music]
I will say
I've always thought it looks very
uncomfortable to have a dick
and balls
well it feels fair I mean I would rather
have this nine months maybe twice in a
lifetime than a dick and balls all the
time you know Roger from my men's rights
groups
he says that having a dick and balls is
like 50 times more painful than giving
birth just the day-to-day experience of
dick and balls and the stress of it you
you land on a plane and it gets hard you
know Roger I did he was in the sex robot
chat room because you know interestingly
like the same way you base how Roger
jerks off on plants in front of my knees
I didn't know until I dated a guy that
kind of had school shooter in cell
energy that he explained to me like and
he was like in high school you always
have a boner he was like in like grade
school like it started or middle school
I guess he's like you start having a
boner and like you just have a boner all
the time and you have to sit at a desk
yeah deal with your boner I was like I
had no idea yeah no one talks about that
no men don't tell girls about that what
are you gonna be like hey I've got a
Bonus so she gonna appetizer no but if
someone just said hey you know because
girls are like high school is so
traumatic we have to go to prom we have
to deal with acne and guys aren't like
we have boners all the time you got to
do the boner walk
is that a book bag it's there isn't a
boner walk but I mean if they invented
something a bone or a harder which they
could never do because it's like that's
what's desk but you need to like but you
if you're coming in to class and your
has just decided like okay I guess
you gotta like do this weird like hobble
and every guy knows what you're doing
like everybody knows everybody knows
every guy I literally did not know that
I was just kind of like guys have it
easy in high school and they're like
he's like we always have a boner it's so
sorry but getting a boner is not like
the worst thing but you're in you're
hiding something you're embarrassed it
is embarrassing no it truly I sort of
used to go through life thinking men did
not deal with embarrassments
until like like
when it when did we start I just mean
like in high school felt feels very
traumatic for girls but now I realize
it's also
traumatic for guys yeah yeah I mean that
is true I don't
you know
we were in the um OB like the office and
this like the the the music that plays
is like like Zen like Tibetan bowls or
something like that and he's like do you
like this music and I was like yeah it's
fine he was like I'm rock hard and I was
like what to do it's like yeah I don't
know just this music wait your boy yeah
yeah not the OB no I'm sorry
is
yeah I need to get new insurance
[Laughter]
um okay last thing is your special
you're shooting it soon when is it
coming out are you excited well yeah
it's this weekend coming up whoa and um
let me let you go yeah you know it's
exciting and there's a lot that like
Lance bangs and I we've come up with
this very cool idea which I don't want
to share yet about what it's going to be
but I'm really I I was already excited
about it now I'm oh are you
shooting it can I ask where you're
shooting it the mothership dick oh sick
and then do you know where you're gonna
release it I don't want to talk about
that okay I got it but um I want it to
be like we're working on that it's
pretty cool though yeah yeah no I'm like
I just was like I'm a little bit of
place wait we keep realizing now on
YouTube you can't say certain things and
I'm just kind of like you know yeah it's
podcast asking yeah yeah no it's not
like some like secret thing it just we
haven't quite like developed this idea
out and I don't want to talk about it
until we're like well I'm certain what
it's going to be but I'm quite excited
about it
okay cool so I'll see you at the show
tomorrow thank you for taking the time
to do this I love you yeah
what do you mean and I forgot 500 of the
things I want to ask but that's probably
a good thing because you got to get to
the gym thank you so much and thanks for
coming on my show you're the best come
on
tell me the pods besides uh uh your main
one don't you have a new one no just a
Duncan Trestle Family Hour nice midnight
gospel on Netflix nice and then you're
which is the most genius thing thank you
love you bye don't ride elephant
[Music]
foreign